sancerre pouilly coteaux du cher vins de
touraine vouvray bourgueil et finaux
notre région est riche en vignoble en va
réputé mais connaissez-vous les vendent
leur lait année sur les rives de la
loire autour d'orléans de
saint-jean-de-braye à bôle de chessy ata
verre de bon vin de terroir dont le
fameux grivegnée faisait la réputation
de cette région
que deviennent ces vignobles à olivet
notamment le charme anthony b de la
belle-époque ont dégusté de bon petit
vin le petit vin blanc convoi soul et
annaëlle comme un agent les vignes
disparaissent et il reste même quelques
vignerons à olivet il nous parle du
passé et du présent
il y avait des cépages autrefois
autrefois des deux ne sait pas ce tardif
des bons sais pas je gâche compte par
exemple
et puis après au moment du phylloxéra
toutes les vignes ont été détruites par
le fils acteur alors il a fallu
remplacer sa demande est d'abord
quelques années pour trouver pour
trouver les cépages de remplacement et
puis à hull et les cépages américain
l'est nord est cantonné vue de la
coopérative et c'est un 20 km en alcool
assez convenable
oui que malcolm à condition qu'ils ne
soient pas cuvée avec l'état qui faisait
le russe est ce qu'il faisait café la
mauvaise renommée du nord il y a plus
que maintenant les quelques jeunes qui
plante des vignes et des vignes haute
maintenant les vignes hautes et larges
où on puisse passer avec un tracteur
comprenez les les jeunes ont ils ont
planté des pommiers
ils ont acheté un matériel pour les
pommiers
il fallait que les vignes soit fait avec
le même matériel et vous vous êtes un
des rares vignerons maintenant avait
prédit l'importance de vignobles en deux
hectares
quels cépages
des hybrides et puis duc à berne
et quelle production savary vous savez
du simple au double l'année dernière une
cinquantaine dectot et cette année il y
en avoir parce que c'est presque ça oui
il se vend y va ou alors le vin voilà
coopérative est faite à la coopérative
est allé coopérative dont le vin est
très bien fait oui on fait tout ce qu'il
faut beaucoup et cette année le levain
la vendange avait mal commencé parce que
mal mûri mais la gelée qui est venu là
ces jours ci les beaucoup d'acidité et
cette année ça va être un millésime tout
à fait minime je me rappelle pas depuis
quarante-sept 1947
voyez ce c'est par là il était bon en
danger au 15 octobre et le 22 octobre
on a dégusté du cabernet à la cave
coopérative faisaient 14 degrés alors ce
vignoble que vous avez est ce rentable
pour vous tester ce que ça rapporte
c'est rentable dans la mesure où un
homme qui à la retraite peut vivre avec
mais ça ne s'est pas rentable ça ne peut
pas ça rentable parce que j'ai gym est
le vieux matériel qui est amorti depuis
un certain temps parce que j'ai un vieux
cheval qui qui comme oliver l'une 12 14
chevaux olive enfin quand le vin est
tiré il faut le boire bas
malheureusement c'est canteloup
après olivet à saint-hilaire marron près
cléry mézières nous trouvons encore des
vignobles comme de l'autre côté de la
loire à meung-sur-loire mais ça c'est
ball ball
c'est un des derniers bastions du riz
meunier un bastion encore solide et
l'activité y est grande mais qu'est
devenu le gris meunier le grivegnée
c'est un vieux crus de la région où ça
remonte loin elle aurait molière montali
720 est qu autrefois c'était le
gouverneur de verna blanc de verna rouge
ils sont trouvés dégénéré revenir de la
remplacer et justement les chroniqueurs
de l'époque avec le grenier à travers un
peu de la qualité et la réputation des
régions
et pourquoi ce nom de gris mounier va
justement le grenier à blé meunier
parce que tout de la faille et un peu
farineuse blanche le plus commenté et
maintenant
et les meuniers c'est un qui avait dans
la région une très bonne réputation et
on en trouve de moins en moins pourquoi
mais pourquoi je pars les jeunes
vignerons désintéresse à la question
laisse tomber un peu ils ont bien planté
les premiers détriment de la vigne et
c'est bien dommage
et quelles sont les qualités de ce vin
son goût vincent vous c'est surtout le
remus terme alléger c'est un but et
c'est ce qui fait sa qualité ensemble
c'est le bouquet et comment se sont
passées ces vendanges finalement très
bien cette année vous l'a dit que ce
serait une année assez moyenne qu'est ce
que vous en ferons au dessus de la
moyenne
non pas un évidement grande année ma
faim moi j'estime au dessus de la
moyenne pour quantité mais la qualité
acceptable
les vignerons continue la tradition et
les vendent leur lait est né sont encore
apprécié il éveille l'esprit sans excès
et glisse avec discrétion comme sonnerie
meunier que mac orlan qualifié de léger
coquin et baba